why don't we get started
so as i like to do let's just
review where we um have been recently um
which is to
um
discuss
context-free languages we talked about
the context-free grammars and the
push-down automata
as a way of describing the context-free
languages
as you remember
the context-free languages are a larger
class of languages than the regular
languages which is where we started the
languages of the finite automata so when
you add a stack you get more power you
get more languages that you can do
and we're very rapidly going to be
moving on today to
our main model for the semester which is
called the turing machine so let's just
take a look at what we're
going to be covering today
and that is
first we're going to show that a
technique analogous to the one we use
for um
[Music]
proving that languages are not regular
but this time for proving languages are
not context free
so the
push down automate and the grammar still
have their limitations in terms of what
we normally think a computer can do
and with that we're going to use that as
a kind of a lead into our
general purpose model which is the
turing machine
and uh
so we're going to talk about turing
machines
and of and aspects of of that um
and i do i would want to make comment uh
so
i have posted the solutions for the
first problem set i know you're starting
to think about the second problem set
now which i have posted as well
if you want to get a sense of what i'm
looking for in terms of the level of
detail
you can look at the solutions to problem
set one because i consider those to be
model solutions uh that's part of the
reason why i post them just to give you
a sense of the level of detail that i'm
looking for which is not a whole lot but
i do want to make sure you're capturing
the main ideas um
of what
of what's involved in solving the
problem
so have a look at those um
and
for problem set two which i'll talk
about um in a second so i'll just say a
few words if you want to pull that up um
you know you can do that but just to get
you started on a few of the problems if
you're
uh finding some challenges there i i
don't want you to get stuck really
before you even understand what the
problem is saying
um
so for problem number one if you looked
at that so that's a problem where you're
asked to prove um a certain language is
not context-free so that's
um and by the way all of the problems in
this problem set except uh perhaps for
the last one for number six you'll be
able to solve we'll have enough material
at the end of today's lecture to solve
all of them um
i believe that's right uh
yeah so number six you should have
enough as of thursday's lecture to solve
that um
um
uh problem number one um
uh it's proving a language is not
context-free so we're going to introduce
a method for doing that that method is
going to come in handy
for parts b and c uh if you look at the
problem set it has this strange looking
thing sigma sigma sigma and parenthesis
star it's really just a regular
expression that's very simple
um you know
you should just make sure you understand
that that's a way of representing all
strings whose length is a multiple of
three
um
and if i stick a sigma in front of that
it's all strings whose length
is one plus a multiple of three
um
so
um
once you understand that and if you
think about what kinds of strings are in
the language c2 it'll help you want to
understand what happens when you take
those unions um
and um
parts b and c are not intended to be
very hard but you just have to
understand what's going on
uh problem number two is about ambiguous
grammars i touched on that briefly in
lecture um
it's enough to solve the problem um the
book has a little bit more detail about
uh
um
ambiguous languages uh ambiguous
grammars
uh
ambiguous grammars i should say um
and uh
so this is a grammar that's supposed to
represent a fragment of a programming
language um
you know with uh if thens um and if then
else's uh you know i'm sure you're all
familiar with uh those kinds of
constructs in programming languages
um and there is a natural ambiguity that
comes up in a programming language you
know if you have
you know if some condition then
statement one else statement two i
presume you understand what the
semantics of that is what that means um
and the tricky thing is that if you have
a you know those statements can
themselves be if statements and so if
you have the situation where you have
if then
and if then else is the uh what follows
that the question is where does the else
attach is it to the second if foot to
the first if um so that's kind of a big
hint on this problem but that's okay um
i think you uh should uh
um uh
you know you need to take that and
figure out how to get a
uh an actual member of the language
which is ambiguously generated um and
then show that it has that show that it
is by showing two parse trees uh
now or or two
left-most derivations if you read the
book you'll see that's an alternative
way of of representing comparison
so um
and then what you're supposed to do is
give a grammar for the same language
which is unambiguous um you don't have
to prove that it's unambiguous because
that's a bit of a chore but as long as
you understand what's going on you
should be should be able to come up with
an unambiguous grammar which resolves
that ambiguity
and i don't have in mind changing the
language by introducing new uh
programming languages contra constructs
like a begin end uh that's not in the
spirit of this problem because
that's a different it's grammar for a
different language so you need to be
generating the same language um without
any other extraneous things going on
that are going to resolve the ambiguity
the ambiguity needs to be resolved
within the structure of the grammar
itself
so keep that in mind
uh for problem number three about the
key automata um you know that came up
actually as a suggestion um uh last
lecture i believe or two lectures back
what happens if you take a push down
automaton but instead of a push down uh
as a instead of a stack you add a q
um what happens then well actually it
turns out that the model you get is very
powerful and turns out to be equivalent
in power to a turing machine so you'll
see arguments of that kind today how you
show that um
other models are equivalent no not today
that's going to be on um
uh
that's going to so i apologize the key
this is going to be something that
you'll also you know i i i i'm confusing
myself here uh for problems number
problem number three you actually need
thursday thursday's lecture as well uh
to really
at least see examples of how you do that
kind of thing
um
and so uh so thursday
uh
yeah so i i i'll try to send out a note
clarifying this by the end of thursday
you'll be able to do everything except
for problem six and for problem six
you'll need tuesday's lecture a week
from today's lecture to do
um
so uh
um all right uh so
um
problem number four that one you'll be
able to do at the end of today we'll
that's also gonna you know the problem
is i'm i'm working on preparing
thursday's lecture too so i'm getting a
little i'm confusing myself uh problem
number four you'll be able to do after
thursday's lecture maybe we should talk
about that um
next lecture
um
problem number five um you can do today
um
but maybe i'm not gonna say anything
about that and problem number six i
won't say anything about either okay so
why don't we just jump in then um and uh
look at today's material um what about
seven seven is uh
oh seven is an optional problem oh i
should have mentioned that whenever
there's seven is always going to be an
optional i indicate that with a star i
should have made that clear um on the
actual description here but seven is
optional uh it's just like we had for
problem set one
okay let's move let's move on then to uh
what we're going to talk about today um
uh
and just a little bit of review um
so we talked about the equivalence of
context-free grammars and push down
automata as you remember oops let me get
myself out of the picture here um
as we mentioned last time we actually
proved one direction but the other
direction of that you just have to know
it's true but you don't have to know the
proof the proof is a little bit lengthy
i would say it's a nice proof but it's
pretty long
um
and uh
there are two uh important corollaries
to that um if you know what a corollary
is just a simple consequence which
doesn't need much of a proof uh sort of
a very straightforward consequence first
of all uh as i think we pointed out at
last time one one conclusion one
corollary you get is that every regular
language is a context-free language
because um a
finite automaton is a push down
automaton that just happens not to use
its stack
so immediately you get that every
regular language is context-free
and second of all um you also
immediately get that
whenever you have a context-free
language and a
and a regular language and you take
their intersection
you get back a context-free language
so context-free intersect regular is
context-free
okay that that's actually mentioned in
your homework as well as one of the
zero-point x problems um which i give to
try to get you um they're not you don't
have to turn those in but i suggest you
look at them i don't know how many of
you are looking at them but uh this is a
useful fact and and some of those other
facts and in zero point x problems are
useful so i encourage you to look at
them
but anyway intersection of context-free
and regular is context-free you might
ask what about intersection of
context-free and context-free do we have
closure under intersection the answer is
no
we do not have close closure under
intersection we'll talk about that
shortly uh so here's the proof sketch
for um
i should i wanted to say that the
intersection of context free and regular
why do we know that's still context-free
because the push down automaton for a
can be simulating the finite automaton
for b
inside its finite control
inside its finite memory
the problem is if you have two
context-free languages you have two
push-down automata you can't simulate
that with one push-down automaton
because it has only a single stack
so if you're trying to take the
intersection of two context-free
language languages with only a single
stack you're going to be in trouble
because it's hard to um
anyway i mean that's not a proof but at
least it shows you what goes wrong if
you try to do the obvious thing
um
okay
uh so
uh
so if
if then just here's an important point
that i was trying to make before if a
and b are both context-free and you take
the intersection
uh the result may not necessarily be a
context-free language um so the class of
context-free languages is not closed
under the intersection we'll comment
down that uh uh in a bit
um
the context-free languages are closed
under the regular operations however
union intersection
a union concatenation and star so you
should um feel comfortable that you know
how to prove that it's in the again it's
one of the
uh
i think it's problem 0.2 and i think the
solution is even given in the book for
it so you just should know how to prove
that um
uh not very
pretty straightforward um okay
so let's move on then
um to uh
to really basically conclude our um work
on context-free languages and to
understand the limitations of uh content
context-free grammars and what kinds of
languages may not be context-free and
how do you prove that so how do you
prove that for some language there is no
grammar
um
again you know it's not enough just to
say
you know
uh given informal
uh
comment that you will i i couldn't think
of a grammar that or some things of that
kind that's not going to be good enough
we need to have a proof
uh so if we take the language here
0 to the k1 to the k2 to the k so those
are strings which are runs of zeros
followed by an equal number of ones
followed by an equal number of twos so
just for zeros then ones then twos all
the same length
um
uh that's a language which is not going
to be a context-free language and we'll
we'll give a method for proving that
you know if you had a stack you can
match the ones with the zeros but then
once you're done with that the stack is
empty and how do you now make sure that
the number of twos corresponds to the
number of ones that you had so again
that's an informal argument that's not
good enough to uh to be a proof but it
sort of gives an intuition um so we're
going to give a method for proving
non-context-free
languages are not context-free using
again
a pumping lemma
but this is going to be a pumping lemma
that applies to context-free languages
not to regular languages okay it looks
very similar but it has some extra
wrinkles thrown in
because the other older
pumping dilemma was specific to the
regular languages and this is going to
be something that applies to the context
free languages
okay so now um let's just read it and
then we'll um
try to interpret it again it's very
similar in spirit basically it says that
whenever you have a context-free
language all long strings in the
language can be pumped
in some kind of way so it's going to be
a little different kind of pumping than
we had before
and you stay in the language
okay so
before we broke the string into three
pieces where we could repeat that center
piece as many times as as you like um
and you stay in the language here we're
going to end up breaking the um the
string into five pieces so s is going to
be broken up into u v x y z um
uh
and
the
and the way it's gonna work here so here
is a picture so all long strings again
there's gonna be a threshold um for
whenever you have a language there's
going to be some cutoff length
so that all the longer strings in that
language can be pumped and you stay in
the language but the shorter strings
there's no guarantee
um so if you have a long string in the
language length at least this pumping
length p
then you can break it up into five
pieces but now it's that
second and fourth string that are going
to play that special uh pumping roll um
which means that what you can do is you
can repeat those
um
and you stay in the language
and it's important that you repeat them
both that v and that y the same number
of times so you're gonna have a picture
that looks something like this
um and that is going to
you you repeat
uh so you can get you if you repeat the
v and repeat the y you get u
v v x y y z um or if you look at over
here it would be u v squared x y squared
is e
um
and that's going to still be in the
language
um and then we have so that's one
condition we'll have to look at all of
these conditions when we do the proof
but we just understand what the
statement is right now so the second
condition is that v and y together
cannot be empty and really that's
another way of saying they can't both be
the empty string because if they were
both the empty string then repeating
them wouldn't change
um
s
and then of course it would stay in the
language so it would be kind of
meaningless if they were allowed to be
empty
and the last thing is again going to be
there as a matter of convenience for
proving str proving
uh languages are not context-free
because
you have to make sure there's no
possible way of cutting up the string
when you're trying to prove a language
is not context-free you have to show the
pumping fails and then you
it's it's going to be helpful sometimes
to limit the ways in which the string
can be cut up because then you have it's
an easier job for you to work with it um
so here it's a little different than
before but sort of similar that v x y
combined um as a substring so i think i
show that over here
v x y together
is a um
is not too long so the v vxy maybe is
better seen up here is going to be is
going to be at most p
um we'll we'll do an example in a minute
of using this okay so
again here's our pumping limit i just
restated it so um you know we have it in
front of us
and we're going to do a proof
i'm just going to give you the idea of
the proof first and then we'll go
through some of the details the idea is
actually pretty simple
okay
i give it a call proof by picture
again remember what we're trying to do
we're trying to show that we have this
context-free language a
and now
all long strings in a have this pumping
quality that you can break them up into
five pieces
so that the second and the fourth piece
can be repeated and you stay in the
language
so how do we know that that's going to
be true
let's take a look at the proof here and
how why is that going to be true
so first of all
i i i'd like to do it qualitatively
rather than quantitatively so let's just
imagine instead of what thinking we'll
calculate what p is later but just
imagine the s is some really really long
string
that's the way i like to think about it
so s is just really long
what is that going to tell us
it's going to tell us something
important
about
the way the grammar produces s
which is going to be useful in in
getting a way of pumping
pumping s
so if s is really long
um
we're going to look at the parse tree
for s
and we're going to conclude that the
parse tree has to be really tall
because it's impossible for a very
shallow
parse tree to generate a very long
string
and again we'll quantify that in a
second but intuitively i think that's
not too hard to see why that ought to be
true so if you have a long s the pole
the parse tree has to be really tall
because the parse tree can't generate
very many it can't expand by very much
at each level
so we'll look at how much it can expand
but it depends on the grammar
how much expansion can we have at each
level and it's going to be you can't
have just in three levels
you know some small grammar generating a
string of length a million just you know
you'll see that that's just impossible
so once you know that the parse tree is
really tall here
um
then you're actually almost done
because what does it mean to be really
tall it means that there's some path
starting at the start variable e i'm
calling it uh in this parse tree
which goes down to some
um
terminal
symbol
in s
which goes through many steps that's
what it means for the tree to be very
tall
and each one of those steps is a
variable until you get down to the very
end
okay so that's the way parse trees look
you keep expanding variables until you
get to a terminal
so here's that here you get some some
path that's really a long path
and once you have a long path that have
many many variables appearing on here
well
the grammar itself has only some fixed
number of variables in it so you're
going to have to have a repetition
coming among the variables that occur on
that long path
got that
so a long string forces a tall
parse tree forces a repetition
on some path coming out of the start
variable
uh of some of some other variable that
comes out
now that's going to tell us how to cut
up s
because if you look at the subtrees of s
that those two r variables are
generating
shown like this
i'm going to use that
so if you have to follow what i'm saying
here so you know the r here is
generating this
portion of s and the lower r is
generating a smaller portion of s
just
looking at the subtree that you get here
um and that's going to tell us that we
can cut up s
accordingly
so u is that very first part out here
generated by e but not by the first r r
is generated v is generated by the first
r but not by the second r the second r
generates exactly x
and then we have y and z similarly
so that all follows from having a lo a
tall
parse tree
and now we're finished
now we know how to cut up s how do we
know
we can repeat
uh v and y and still be in the language
well i'll actually show your and show
you that you're in the language by
exhibiting a parse tree for the string u
v v x y y z here it is
what i'm gonna get that parse tree by
when i expand this lower r
instead of expanding it to get x i'm
going to follow the same substitutions
that i i had when i expanded the upper r
so it's as if i took this larger subtree
here and i substituted it in for the
smaller uh subtree under under the
second r and so that i get a picture
that looks like this
so here i'm substituting under the
second r the same subtree that i had
originally coming out of the upper r the
first r
and so now this parse tree is generating
the string u v v x y y z
which is what i'm looking for and of
course you can do that again and again
and you're going to keep getting higher
and higher exponents of v and y
um
and in fact you can even get the zero
exponent which means that v and y both
disappear altogether
and for that you do something slightly
different which is that you replace
the larger subtree by the smaller
subtree
okay so here which was originally that
larger subtree generating v x y i stick
instead the smaller subtree i do the
substitutions from the smaller sub tree
and i just get x uh there and so now the
string i generated is u xz which is the
same as u v to the zero x y to the zero
z
okay that's that is the idea of the
proof
now i think
uh you could work out um
[Music]
the quantities that you need in order to
drive this proof um i'm gonna do that
for you i actually hate writing down
lots of inequalities and um
equations and so on on the board because
i think they're just almost
incomprehensible to follow at least they
would be for me but i'm going to put
them up there just for completeness sake
um
so here we're going to give the details
of this proof on the next uh the next
slide here
oh yeah so i just want to give a name to
this i'm going to call this the cutting
and pasting argument because i'm cutting
apart
pieces of this parse tree and i'm
pasting them into other places within
the parse tree to get new strings being
generated
so this is a cutting and pasting
argument so okay let's let's take a look
at the details here um
uh just so we have to understand well
how big does p actually need to be
in order for this thing to kick in
um
well first of all we have to understand
how fast that parse tree can be growing
um as we go level to level and that's
going to be dependent on how big the
right-hand side sides of rules are i
mean that's expand that really tells you
how many what's the fan out you know of
each node
what's the maximum fanout and that's
going to be the maximum uh
length of a right-hand side of any rule
so for example in that other grammar we
had seen last time
for arithmetic expressions we had this e
goes to e plus t and
uh this rule here and in terms of the
parse tree that would look uh like an a
little element like that
and that's actually the longest right
hand side that you can get and so the
parse tree can be growing by a factor of
three each time
now that's going to tell us
how
big the string uh
needs to be that's being generated what
is the value of p in order to get a
high enough parse tree so that you're
going to get a repeated variable
okay um
let's call the height of the parse tree
for sh
okay
so now if you this is just repeating
what i just said if you have a tree of
height h and the maximum branching is b
then you get it most b to the h leaves
because each level you get another
factor of b coming up because that's how
much branching you have
so each node at one level can become b
nodes at the next level down so you're
multiplying by b each time and if you
have h levels you're going to have b to
the h leaves
so the length of s which are really the
leaves here that it is at most b to the
a the reason why i said most and not
exactly is you might be doing
substitutions which are shorter right
hand sides
um
okay so to try to show this as a picture
here uh
pulling that same picture we had before
we want h
the height to be bigger than the number
of variables
to force a repetition
so the number of variables is going to
be written this way v is the variables
uh v with bars around it is going to be
the number of variables and we want that
height to be greater than the number of
variables
so once you know how high you want that
tree to be in order to force the
repetition
then it tells you how big s has to be
so b has to be bigger
than b to the v b to the size of v
um because then
um the the the height that you're going
to get is going to be greater
than uh
uh the size of v which is uh so that's
what you want you want h to be greater
than the size of v
uh so you're gonna set p to be one more
than b to the v
and so if s is at least that length
this whole thing is going to kick in and
you're going to get that repeated
variable um
so we let p to be that value where v is
the number of variables in the grammar
and so if
s
is at least p
which is greater than b to the v
then the length of s is going to be
greater than
um b to the v so h is going to be what
you want to make this thing work
i
you know if you don't follow that those
inequalities i sympathize with you i
would never follow that either in a
lecture so
um but i hope you get the idea um but
you know we're not quite finished yet
because what i want to now circle back
as and look at these three conditions
and make sure
that we've captured them all because
actually it's not totally
uh obvious um
in each of those cases that we've got
them um so there's a few extra things we
need to do um um
okay so this is concluding the argument
you know there are going to be at least
three plus one variables in the longest
path so there's going to be a repetition
so now let's go back here and see now
that we have this picture
with a repeated uh variable
how do we know we can get condition one
well that's just the cutting and pacing
argument from the previous slide
how do we know that v and y are not both
empty
well actually that's not totally obvious
because it's possible
that when you generated v here and you
generated y
um maybe going from this r to that r you
got nothing new
you know it could have been that r got
replaced by t
another variable with nothing new coming
out and then t got replaced by r so you
substituted uh
you know t for r and then r for t and
you've got nothing new coming out and in
that case uh v and y would both be the
empty string and that would violate what
we want
um
the way you
get around that and these are details
here if you're not totally following
these points don't worry uh but i do
want to just try to it's easy they're
easy to describe so i figure let me
present the whole thing in full detail
so if going from this r to that r
doesn't generate anything new you're
getting exactly the same things coming
out v and y are just
the empty string
um how do we avoid that from happening
well what there's a simple way to
address that which is to say
uh if you have
this string s
when you take a parse tree make sure you
take a smallest possible parse tree
you cannot you're not allowed to start
off with an inefficient parse tree that
can be shortened and still generate s i
want the smallest possible parse tree
and that smallest possible parser can't
have an r going to another r which is
generating nothing new because then you
could always have eliminated that step
and you would still have a parse tree
for s but it would be a smaller parse
tree so that would be i want you to
start off with the smallest possible
parser tree and then you're going to be
guaranteed that v or y is going to be
something uh not empty so that takes
care of
uh condition two
condition three
uh
you know how do we know that v x
y together is not very long
and basically it's the same argument all
over again um you just want to make sure
that when you're picking the repetition
are the two r's here you pick the lowest
possible repetitions that occur if you
have many many choices
and those lowest two those lowest
repetitions there's not going to be any
lower repetition here and then by the
same argument um the the uh
since once you have that very first r
there's no more repetitions occurring
below
the v x y can't be very long um because
that would again force another
repetition to occur
um so anyway those are the three
conditions and that's the proof of the
pumping lemma for context-free languages
let's see how we use that
um
okay so let's do an example of proving a
language not context free using the
pumping line
how do you gonna do a go about doing
that because that's the kind of thing
you you know
at the very least you need to know how
to do this in order to do the homework
um
uh i'd like to motivate you that the
stuff is so interesting and fun but it
doesn't work for everybody so
uh for you practical people out there um
pay attention so you can do the homework
okay let's go back to that language we
had a couple of slides back zero to the
g one to the k two to the k it's not a
contact three language we're gonna show
that now using the pumping lemma for
context-free languages
um
uh so it's gonna do
similar to the proofs using for
non-regular non-regul not non-regular
languages um proof by contradiction so
you first you assume the language is
context-free and then we're going to
apply the pumping lemma um and then
we're going to get a contradiction uh
so the pumping limit gives that pumping
length as we subscribed above and now we
just want to pick a longer string in the
language
and show that that
longer string which is supposed to be
pumpable and stay in the language in
fact is not pumpable
um
so the pumping dilemma says that you can
divide it into five pieces satisfying
the three conditions uh condition three
implies
uh that
so now i'm gonna i'm gonna work through
the i'm gonna uh show you get a
contradiction so condition three
implies that you cannot contain both
zeros and let's pull up a picture here
so here's s
uh
zeros ones and then twos all the same
length condition three
uh so if you break it up
condition three says v x y together
cannot be too long well if v x y
together is not too long
uh what you know how could it be that
when you're repeating v and y you stay
in the language
uh for one thing you can't have
zeros ones and twos all occurring within
v x and y
um
some
uh some symbol is going to get left out
so then when you pump up you're going to
have unequal numbers of symbols
and so you're going to be out of the
language
um
okay so no matter how you try to cut it
up uh following condition three which is
one of the things that restricts the
the ways to cut it up you're going to
end up when you pump up
uh going out of the language and so
therefore it's not in
d
d is wrong
uh
b shouldn't say b
can knife can i
nice
supposed to be able to write on this
thing i guess not
i didn't test that
oh well that's supposed to be a b
um
uh so b is a context free language we
close
so that's the assumption that b is a
context-free language that's false and
we conclude that's not a context-free
language okay
let's do uh
oh yeah
i have a check-in here
um
so let's see um what we're going to
we're going to i'm going to ask you to
think about
okay
my head is blocking part of the text
oh that was a while ago um okay uh
yes so with just one question by the way
in in terms of applying the um in in the
pumping dilemma either v or y can be uh
empty but not both but anyway let's get
to this check in here
um
so let's look at these two languages a1
and a2 which look very similar to b
but a little different
um so it's a1 is 0 to the k1 to the gate
2 to the l
where k and l could be any numbers any
positive
you know uh non-negative numbers
so basically what this says saying is
that the number of zeros and ones are
going to be equal but the number of twos
can be anything
whereas a2
similar
but here we're requiring the number of
two ones and twos
to be equal and the number of zeros can
be anything
okay
now you can easily make i hope
uh you should make sure you you can
push down automata that can recognize a1
and a2
um because let's just take a1
the push down automaton can push the
zeros
as it's reading them
pop them as it's reading the ones to
match them off and make sure that
they're the same number of them
and then the twos
it doesn't care how many there are it
just has to make sure that there are no
strings there are no letters coming out
of order but any number of twos is fine
so you can easily make a presentation
recognize a1 similarly for a2
um so what can we conclude from that
here are the three possibilities let me
uh so look at that the class of content
language is not closing intersection
you know you can read it um so i i want
to pull up the uh
poll and launch that
please fill that out
um
10 seconds
again
just
if you don't know the answer just give
any answers so that uh because we're not
counting correctness
um
still a few dribbling in
okay
uh
five seconds
okay end polling uh most of you got that
right
um
i know is it okay to share these things
i don't want to make people who didn't
get the right feel bad
you know but you should understand i
think you know if you're missing
something you should understand
what is what you're missing the pumping
limit shows that a1 union a2 is not a
context-free language no as i mentioned
at the beginning the reg the
context-free languages are closed under
union
so the pumping alum had better not show
that these we already know that these
two languages are context-free because
we get them from push down on top
and we said at the beginning that
contact free language is closed under
union so we know that these two are
context-free so the pumping alignment
better not show it they're not
context-free something would be terribly
gone have gone terribly wrong uh
if that were true and also
um
we know
also from a little bit of further
reasoning that the context-free
languages is not closed under complement
by what we've already what we've already
discussed
uh because they are closed under union
as i pointed out they're not closed
under intersection
and so if they were closed under
complement
de morgan's laws would say that closure
under union and closure under complement
would give you closure under
intersection
but we don't have closer intersections
so in fact they're not closed under
complement
okay uh so in fact this does show us
that the class of context-free language
is not closed under intersection because
the intersection of a1 and a2 two
context three languages is b
and b
is not context-free so it shows that um
this is not the the
um closure under intersection does not
hold
okay um
so let us continue then
we have one more uh example then we'll
take a break
uh so the pumping limit for context-free
languages again uh here's a second
example
uh here's the language f we have
actually seen what's before ww
uh two copies of a string um in in
um
that
two copies of any string um i'm gonna
show that's not a context free language
uh
assume that it is context-free the
pumping limit gives pumping length now
here you have to do a little bit more
often the challenge
in applying
the pumping lemma in either case uh that
we've seen uh involves with choosing
that string that you need to pump that
you're gonna pump
so you have to choose s uh in f which is
longer than p which has to go with so
you might try this one first glance here
isn't string it's in the language
because it's
two copies of the string zero to the p1
zero to and then zero to the p1 that's
in the language
but it's a bad choice
uh let's say let's before i get ahead of
myself let's let's draw a picture of
this which i think is always helpful to
see
um so here is runs of zeros and then a
one runs of zeros and then a one um why
is this a bad choice
because you can pump that string and you
remain in the language um there is a way
to cut that string up
um and you'll stay in the language and
the way to cut it up is to let the x be
just that substring which is just the
one
and the v and the y can be a couple of
zeros or a single zero on either side of
that one
and now that's going to be a small
v x y
but
if you repeat v and y you're going to um
if you repeat v and y
you're going to stay in the language
because you'll just be adding zeros here
you'll be adding same number of zeros
there
and then you're going to have a string
which still looks like ww and you'll
still be in the language
so that
that means of cutting it up doesn't get
you out of the language under pumping
and the fact is that
that's a bad choice for s because there
is that way of cutting it up so you have
to show there's no way you can't you
don't get to pick the way to cut it up
um you have to show that there is no way
to cut it up um
uh in order to um
to violate the uh
the pumping lever so
if instead you use the string 0 to the
p1 to the p0 to the p1 to the p so this
is zeros followed by one followed by
zeros followed by ones all the same
number of them
that can't be pumped satisfying to the
three conditions um
and just going through that
uh
um now if you try to break it up you're
going to lose
or the or the lemon is going to lose
you're going to be happy but the lemon
is not going to be happy because it's
not going it's going to violate the
conditions um
condition 3 says
vxy is not
doesn't span too much and in fact can't
span
uh two runs of zeros or two runs of ones
it's just not big enough because they're
more than p things they're p things
apart
and this one string this string v x y is
only p long
and so therefore if you repeat
of uh v and y
you're going to have two runs of zeros
or two runs of ones that have unequal
length and now
that's not going to be of the form w and
you're going to be out of the language
okay uh so i hope
you know that's uh you've got a little
practice with that um i think we're at
our
uh break and i will see you back here in
uh five uh minutes um
i can get my timer launched here
okay so see you soon
you can this is a good time by the way
to to um
uh message me or the tas and i'll i'll
try to be uh
looking for if you have any questions
in the pumping limit can x
x can be epsilon in the pumping lemma uh
but it's not possible x can be epsilon y
can be epsilon but x and y cannot be
both cannot both be epsilon
because then when you pump you will get
nothing new
technically v and y can include both
zeros and ones
yeah
v and y can conclude both zeros and ones
um
so
let me uh
try to put that back if that's
will
um
[Music]
so v and y can have both zeros and ones
but they can't have zeros from two
different blocks
and you can't have ones from two
different blocks
so what's going to happen is either
you're going to get things out of order
when you repeat like a v has both zeros
and ones in it when you repeat
v you're going to have uh zeros and ones
and zeros and ones and zeros and ones
that's clearly out of the language so
that's so that's no good
your only hope is to have v to be
sticking only inside the zeros and y to
be sticking only inside zeros are only
inside once
but now if you repeat that if just look
at what you're going to get
you're going to have a string which is
going to be
if you try to cut that string in half
it's not going to be of the right form
it's not going to be two copies of the
same string because you know it's going
to have a run of zeros
um followed by
a longer or shorter run of zeros or one
of ones followed by another run of ones
of unequal length so there's no way this
can be two strings
um
two copies of the same string
because that that's what you're required
f has to be two copies of the same
string to be in the language
okay uh let me just see where we're
running out of time here let me just put
my uh
my
my
timer here
we've only got 30 seconds
okay sorry i'm not getting to answer all
the questions here um
okay we are done um
uh
with um
our break
it's going to come back
um and now we're shifting gears in a
major way
because in a sense everything we've done
so far
has been kind of a warm up
these limited
computational models
um
really are kind of
get helping us to set our understanding
of automata and the definitions and the
notation
and they're also going to be helpful in
providing examples later on in the term
um but really in terms of a model of
computation they don't cut it because
uh they cannot do very simple things
that we normally think of a computer as
being able to do
so here we're introducing another model
of computation called the turing machine
and that's really going to be the model
that we're going to stick with for the
rest of the semester because that's
going to be our model of a general
purpose uh
computer the way you normally think
about it
um
so let's uh we'll spend a little time
introducing it and then we will um
uh
you know we'll
we'll continue that discussion next time
um
so uh in terms of a schematic actually
the turing machine model is pretty
simple
um
it has a uh
it has um
it's going to have states and all that
stuff but you know though so there's
going to be a finite control here which
is going to include the states and
transition function as we'll describe in
a minute um the point is is that you
know it's going to have the input
appearing on a tape
uh
the key difference now is that the the
machine is going to be able to change
the symbols on the tape um
and so we think of the machine as being
able to write as well as read the tape
okay so that's really uh the key
uh
feature
um of a turing machine is the ability to
write on the tape everything else in a
sense follows from that
a few other differences
but so the fact that he he head can read
and write
so we can use the tape as
storage
much as we used a stack as storage but
it doesn't it's not limited in the way
we can access it the way a stack is so
that we kind of have very uh
flexible access of the information on
the tape
now
being able to write on the tape doesn't
do any good if you can't go back and
read what you've written later on so
we're going to make the head to be able
to be two-way
so the head can move left to right as
before but it can also move back left
and that's going to be under control of
the transition function so under under
program control essentially
the tape is going to be
oops
sorry the tape is infinite to the right
and
so we're not going to limit how much
storage the machine can have so the tape
is going to think of as having instead
of just having the input on it it's
going to have the input but then the
rest is going to have infinitely many
blanks
blank symbols following the input so the
tape is infinite or
in the right right hand direction
um
and uh so there's infinitely many blanks
i'm going to use that symbol for the
blank to follow the input
um you can accept or reject oh yeah so
that's another thing that's important
normally we think of the machine in the
previous machines
finding a time when i pushed down
automata when you got to the end of the
input that's when you the acceptance of
rejection was decided if you were in
except state at the end of the input
then you accept it but
you have to be in that location um at
the end of the input in order for that
to take effect
that doesn't make any sense anymore
because
the machine might go off beyond that and
still be computing and come back and
read the tape later on so it only really
makes sense to let the machine
accept or reject
upon entering the accept or the reject
state so we're going to have a special
accept state and a special reject state
which is also a little different than
before
and when the machine enters those states
then machine then the action takes
effect the machine those machine holds
and then accepts
or holds and then it rejects so we'll
make that absolutely clear in the formal
definition in a second but just to get
the spirit of it
um
so i'm going to give you an example of
the thing running uh sorry you need to
again my
powerpoint is having issues
um
uh
okay so here is a turing machine
recognizing that language b
actually i switched gears on you instead
of zeros ones and twos i made them a's
b's and c's but same idea
[Music]
so i'm going to show you how the turing
machine operates
and then we'll give a formal
uh definition i hope that's on here
i think it is
in a second but let's this is an
informal discussion of how the machine
is going to operate to do this language
a to the kb to the kc to the k using its
ability to write on the tape as well as
read and move its head in both
directions
okay so let me just first describe
um in english
how this um
[Music]
machine operates and then we will um
see it in action on this little uh
picture i have over here okay so the way
the machine is going to operate is the
very first thing is the head is going to
start here and the head is going to scan
off to the right
uh making sure that the symbols appear
in the correct order
so it's seeing that
that there are a's and then b's and then
c's without checking the quantities just
that the order is correct for that you
don't need to write a finite automaton
can check that the input is of the form
a star b star c star
um
so uh
rioting is not necessary
the machine if it uh detects symbols out
of order it immediately rejects by going
into a special reject state otherwise
it's going to return its head back to
the left end
and um
uh let me just show that here so here is
it
oh no
i better
before i illustrate it over here let's
go through the whole algorithm uh so the
next thing that happens is you're going
to scan right and now you want to do the
counting so you're going to scan right
again but this time you're going to make
a bunch of passes over the input bunch
of scans
and each time you make a scan you're
going to cross
off one symbol of each type so you're
going to cross off an a you'll cross off
a b you'll cross off a c on a single
scan and then repeat that
crossing off the next a the next b the
next c
and
you want to make sure that you've
crossed off all of the symbols on the
same run and not crossing off some
symbols before other symbols uh while
other symbols will remain because that
would mean that the counts were not
equal if you cross them off and they're
all
you know run out on the same scan
same pass
then we know that the numbers have to be
start off being equal sort of i mean
this is sort of baby stuff here i but i
hope you get the idea and we'll kind of
illustrate in in a second so if at least
one of the if you have the last one of
each symbol so what i mean by that is
you you just crossed off the last a the
last b and the last c then you know that
you were originally had an equal number
and so you accept because you're
crossing off one of each on each scan so
if you cross the
on the last scan
each one of them gets crossed off um
then you accept
but if
uh it was the last of some symbol but
not of other symbols
so you know you crossed off the last a
but there um there were several b's
remaining then you started off with an
unequal number of a's b's and c's
and you can reject or
if all symbols still remain after you've
crossed them uh one of each off
then you haven't
done enough passes and you're gonna
repeat
from stage three and do that uh again
another scan
okay so here's a little um animation
which shows this happening on this
diagram so here is
the very first stage where you're
scanning across making sure things are
in the right order
um didn't have to write on the tape and
now you're gonna
reset the the head back to the beginning
this is by the way not the most
efficient procedure for doing this um
so um
now that now we're going to do a scan
crossing off a single a a single b and a
single c
so here i'm going to show that here
single a single b single c
and now as soon as you've crossed out
that last c we can return back to the
beginning um
so scan right cross
uh so if all symbols remain so there are
still symbols remaining of each type
we're going to return to the left and
repeat and repeat
now we'll get another pass single a
single b single c get crossed off
we haven't crossed them all off yet
no there's
of each type there's still our remaining
ones so again we return back to the
beginning now we have a last pass
crossover the last a the last be the
last c the last one of each type was
crossed off so now we know we can accept
because the original string was in the
language
okay so that's
uh to give you at least some idea um
that how the turing machine can operate
you know more like the way you would
think of a computer operating you know
maybe it's very primitive you know you
you could imagine counting also and the
termination can count as well but this
is the simplest uh descript uh procedure
that i can just describe on um you know
uh
for you without getting making too
complicated um
okay so let's do a little checking on
that um
okay so
the way i'm describing this
how do we go how do you think
and you in a sense you don't quite know
enough yet but um
[Music]
uh how do you think we're going to get
this effect
of crossing off with the turing machine
um are we going to get that by
changing the model and adding that
ability to cross off to the model
um are we going to use a tape alphabet
that includes those crossed off symbols
among them
or um we'll just assume that all turing
machines come with the eraser and they
can always cross our stuff
um so what do you think is the
nice way sort of mathematically to
describe
this
this ability to cross things off
yeah again again most of your again i
think are getting this um
uh
so
like 10 laggards here so
please wrap it up um so we can
close the poll
uh
five seconds to go
um
okay
polling ending get your last last call
uh
all right
share the results
so most of you
uh got that right
all turn machines come with an eraser i
don't know that was thrown in there as a
joke but it got came in second so i
don't feel bad if you got it but that's
not what i had in mind
um the the way the turing machine is
going to be riding on the tape is to
write a crossed off symbol uh instead of
the uh
the symbol that was originally there so
we're going to add these new crosstalk
symbols and that's going to be a common
thing for us to do
in um you know when we design turing
machines we're not going to get down to
the implementation level for very long
we're going to very quickly shift to a
higher level of discussion about the
machines but anyway that's how you would
do it if you were going to actually
build a machine
okay so um
let us then look at the formal
definition of the cursing and maybe i
should have done that checking after the
formal definition that might have been
clear but oh well
uh
okay here's the formal definition this
time a turing machine is a seven
tuple um
and
there is a
uh
um
now here
uh we have sigma which is the input
alphabet gamma is the tape alphabet so
now you're it's sort of a little bit
analogous to the stack from before where
gamma was the stack alphabet but these
are the symbols that you're allowed to
write on the tape um or that are allowed
to be on the tape um
so uh obviously all of the input symbols
are among the uh tape uh symbols
because they can appear on the tape so
you have sigma
is a subset of gamma um
one thing i didn't mention here is that
the input alphabet
we don't allow the blank symbol to be uh
in the input alphabet so that
you can actually use the blank symbol as
a delimiter for the end of the input
a marker for the end of the input um so
uh in fact and blank symbol is always
going to be in the tape alphabet uh so
we have um
you know
the this is actually always going to be
a proper subset uh because of the blank
symbol um what we're just allowing
doesn't really matter we're allowing the
tape alphabet to have
other symbols for convenience so for
example these crossed off symbols
now let's look at what the transition
function how that operates so the
transition function remember tells how
the machine is actually doing its
computation
and it says that if you're in a certain
state and the head is looking at a
certain tape symbol
um
then you can go to a new state you write
a new symbol on the uh
at that location on the tape and you can
move the head either left or right
so that's how we get the effect of the
head being able to be bi-directional
and here's the writing on the tape
comes up right here so
you know just an example here we says if
we're in state q and the head is looking
at an a currently on the tape then we
can move to state r we change it a to a
b and we move the head right once one
square
okay um
uh
uh now here this is important
to
on when you're giving a certain input
here to the turing machine it may gr
compute around for a while moving its
head back and forth as we were showing
and it may eventually halt by either
entering the q accept state or the q
reject state which i didn't
uh bring out here but that's important
these are the accepting rejecting
special states of the machine um or the
machine may never enter one of those it
may just go on and on and on and never
halt
we call that looping
a little bit of a misnomer because it's
the looping implies some sort of a
repetition for us looping just means not
holding
um
and um
so therefore m has three possible
outcomes for each um input
w it might accept w
by uh entering uh the except state
it could reject w by entering the reject
state which means it's going to reject
it by holding
or we also say we can reject by looping
you can reject the string by running
forever
um
okay that's just the terminology that's
common in the subject so you either
accept it um by halting and accepting or
rejecting it by either holding and
rejecting or by just going forever
that's also considered to be rejecting
sort of
sort of rejecting the instance by
default if you never actually have
accepted it then it's going to be
rejected
okay uh
checking three here
all right
so now um our last check in for the day
we say this turing machine model is
deterministic
um
i'm just saying that but if you look at
the way we set it up
if you've been following these formal
definitions so far you would understand
why it's deterministic so let's just as
a way of checking that um how would we
change this definition because we will
look on at the next lecture at
non-deterministic turing machines so a
little bit of a lead into that how would
we change
this uh definition to make it a
non-deterministic turing machine which
of those three options would we use
so here i'll launch that poll
uh
got about 10 people left let's give them
another 10 seconds
um
okay i think that's everybody who's
answered it from before
um
here there is so here
i think you pretty much
almost all of you got the right idea uh
it is b in fact uh because when we have
the power set symbol here that means
there might be several there's a subset
of possibilities so that indicates
several different ways to go
um
uh and that's what the that's the
essence of non-determinism
okay so uh i think we're
uh
whoops
um
okay
all right
so look
this is also kind of setting us up for
next lecture
and where we're going to be going with
this um so these are uh
basically two in example two or three
important definitions here um
one is um
we have we talked about the regular
languages
from fine automata we talked about the
context free languages from the grammars
and the push down automata what are the
languages of that the touring machines
can do
those are called in this course anyway
turing recognizable languages is very
orti recognizable um those are the lang
those are the languages that the turing
machine can recognize
and so what
just to make sure we were on the same
page on this
the language of the machine is the
collection of strings that the machine
accepts
so the things that are not in the
language are the things that are
rejected either by looping or by halting
and projecting
so all the only the ones that are
accepted are the light is the language
every machine has just a single language
it's a language of all strings that that
machine accepts um
and we'll say that m recognize that
language if that language is
a collection of such strings that are
accepted
and uh we will call that language a
touring recognizable language
okay if there's some turing machine that
can recognize it
um now uh
this feature of being able to reject by
running forever is a little bit weird
perhaps um
uh
and
uh for from the standpoint of
practicality
uh it's more convenient if the machine
always makes a decision to accept or
reject in a finite time
and doesn't just reject by going forever
and so we're going to
bring out a special class of turing
machines that have that feature
that they always halt they always go to
the holding states by the way maybe
didn't say this explicitly are the q
accept and the q eject states the accept
and reject states are the holding states
so the machine halts that means it ends
up in one of those two so it has made a
decision of accepting or rejecting in in
by the at the point in which it has
halted
um so we'll say a machine is a decider
if it always holds on every input
uh so for every w feed in the machine is
eventually going to come to a q accept
or to reject we call such a machine a
decider
and now we're going to say a language
uh
is that so it will say that the machine
decides a language
if
if it's the language of the machines of
the collection of accepted strings uh
and the machine is a decider so we'll
say that instead of just recognizing the
language we'll say that it decides the
language
um
and a turing decidable language is a
language um
that the machine
of all strings the machine accepts uh
for some turing machine which is is a
decider which is a touring machine that
always holds
so if a turing machine may sometimes
reject by looping then it's only
recognizing this language if the turing
machine is always holding so it's always
rejecting by explicitly coming to a
reject state and halting then we'll say
it's actually deciding the language
so in a sense that's better and we're
going to distinguish between those two
because
um
they're not the same
uh there are some languages which can be
recognized but not decided
and so in fact we're going to get the
following picture here
the deteuring recognizable languages are
a proper subset they include all this
everything that's decidable certainly is
going to be recognizable
because um
uh you know this being a decider is an
additional restriction to impose
additional requirement
so everything that's decidable is going
to be automatically recognizable but
there are things which are recognizable
but you're not decidable as we'll see
um
i'll actually give an example of that
but not prove it next lecture
and just for just to complete out this
picture um
i'm going to uh
also point out we haven't proven this
yet but uh we will prove it um that the
decidable languages also include
all the context-free languages which in
turn include the regular languages as it
was already seen so we haven't shown
this inclusion yet but actually this is
the picture we we get um so there's
actually a hierarchy of containments
here
regular languages are
a subset of the
context-free languages which are in turn
a subset of the decidable languages
which are in turn are a subset of the
recognizer turing recognizable languages
um and so
with that i think we're going to move to
our little bit of a review of what we've
done today
so we proved that pumping lemma
as a tool for showing that languages are
not context-free languages
we define turing machines which is going
to be our model um
that we're going to be focusing on for
the rest of the term uh not forgetting
the other models because they're going
to be useful examples for us
and we define touring deciders turing
machine deciders that halt and all
inputs
okay so i think with that um we have
come to the end of today's lecture
um i will stick around a little bit and
answer questions in the chat um i will
try to share them with everybody um as
i'm answering them so i'm not just
talking to one person
how was the concept of pride applied in
so i'm getting one question about
the practicality of all this uh bunches
of questions are coming in
um
uh
so look uh
is this is this stuff all practical um
uh i would say um uh yes and no um
uh
i i don't know which concept you have in
mind we're going to introduce lots of
concepts in this course and
um uh the you know the concept of
um
uh of you know the fine art automata and
the push down automata and context-free
languages
definitely used in other
subjects in other fields in computer
science and elsewhere these are very
basic and fundamental notions
um and so yes and turing machines well i
mean that's a model of a general
computer if you want to understand
computation you're going to need to
understand some model and a turing
machine is a particularly simple model
and that's why we use it as it turns out
it doesn't really matter what model you
use but we'll talk about that next
next time but yeah i would say there's a
lot of applied material in this course
as time has shown
whether it's
led to things like public key
cryptography which is
used on the internet
or you know understanding various
algorithms
i mean
that's not the reason i study it i'd
study it because i'm more of them coming
at it from more of a mathematical
perspective i just find the material
very uh beautiful and interesting and
challenging um but it does have
applications um
any other questions here i think i'm
going to sign off then so get myself set
up for my office hours which is in a
different on a different zoom like
okay so thank you everybody and see you
uh on thursday bye